das ist wirklich eine unglaubliche
geschichte im fragen lottomittel floyd
klärt sich warum er augenringe hat das
ist nämlich nicht genetisch bedingt wie
vielleicht der ein oder andere vermutet
sondern hat tatsächlich mit schlafmangel
zu tun und dafür gibt es einen ganz
besonderen grund sehr spannend und
spannend ist auch was er dazu sagte zu
der frage die wir alle beantwortet
wissen wollen warum hier zu viele tippen
in seinem vom netz das und viel mehr
jetzt im fragen otto weiß das
unvermeidliche ja nicht vermeiden
ich bin auch schon seit du mir bescheid
gesagt hast wegen interview und so hin
und her gerissen aber ich mich auf das
fragen lotto am meisten freue ja oder
nicht oder sogar nicht im sinne von 0
und ich weiß immer noch nicht gut
ich glaube ich werde mir gleich mal so
ein ding rein würden ein rotes ok und
dann wahrscheinlich mann im grünen
konnten also wichtig schnauze voll hat
aber muss erstmal sein also weiß wir
versuchen schon das war schon immer
wissen wie die aussehen und warum die so
einfach zu öffnen sind es gibt ich habe
mal vor vielen vor zwei jahren habe ich
mein tutorial video gemacht für meine
kollegen wenn ich es nicht also manchmal
passt es manchmal wie bastelt man fragen
laut los warum machst du so oft frauen
und titten in dieses amt mails reichen
die deiner freunde nicht oder das du
klick geil ich habe als ich sie gerade
aufgeblättert einfach ich mir gedacht da
kommen die frauen und twitter
das ist kein thema meine freundin
getrennt sagten wir ja ganz schön bitter
in die richtung gar keine defizite ok
darum machen deswegen mutu generieren
sagt kein thema m
klick geil natürlich will ich dass meine
videos gesehen werden da hängt arbeit
drin da will man tatsächlich und jeder
der was anderes behauptet lügt
natürlich will ich dass meine videos
gesehen ich will dass sich das lohnt die
arbeit die man da rein steckt das
herzblut was man da rein steckt aber das
mit den frauen und tippen hat mich dann
irgendwann meine community tatsächlich
hatte die
sowieso geilste community überhaupt muss
ich sagen ich glaube ich also ich feiere
meine community so eine geile communitys
höre ich von keinem anderen youtuber
aber die haben mich richtig ja nett und
objektiv darauf aufmerksam fort und ich
bin ja jetzt auch tatsächlich am abbauen
ich bin ja schon gut abgedeckt gekommen
sagte ich jetzt einfach mal weil ich
einfach denke der der seriösität halber
zu das den videos im fern- ähnlich auf
dauer gut als angebracht ist okay messen
tippen
ich mag wusste doch überreden aber von
da her
ja es stimmt schon also das schränkt ich
ein wobei die klimadiskussion ist
ziemlich veräppelt ja das finde ich
super weil die leute begriff namen ja
man braucht er klicks ohne funktioniert
ohne klicks auch mit dem content dann
schwierig so weiter und so fort und wenn
ich halt überlege was so eine ausrüstung
kostet um gut sieben minuten kurzfilm zu
erstellen was beispielsweise auch mal
eine drehgenehmigung neben dem scheiß
mtv gebäude einer spree gekostet hat und
so weiter und so fort
sind die sachen ja so holte mit regen na
ja nicht wenn ich absolut vermeiden kann
wir haben keine aber das war ein spot
der war unfassbar geil aber der war
leider voll im augenmerk von den
mitarbeitern und doch kamen dann vor
allem hinterher
quasi eine nachträgliche weil die
gebäude auch mal drauf ist und so einen
scheiß okay
lieber so als sich da irgendwie anwalt
technisch über den tisch ziehen zu
lassen
weiter geht's weiter geht mir ja noch
mal war gar nicht so schlimm wie war
nicht so schlimm
naja ich war auf einer persönlichen
ebene einmal kurz wies aber wird das
lässt sicher abtun
ja gut also leute die man den mann so
rothe fragen stellen kann dass sie
wirklich persönlich geleitet die habe
ich ja gar nicht als gast dj ötzi kann
ich mich daran erinnern aber ich habe
bis heute nicht verstehen warum so ein
bisschen und dann hat das ja auch wieder
ein bisschen relative dem habe ich
wirklich kein schlips getreten aber er
muss damit rechnen wenn er sagt wir
müssen fragen die roben tragen sind
diese fragen warum zeigst du so viel
gewalt verherrlichen gewalt das ist eine
rote frage korrekte typ das euch nichts
grösseres eingebracht moment gewalt
verherrlichen ist was total schlimme ist
ich glaube du hast wird noch nicht hast
du dir mal kinder super rtl nachmittags
fernsehen angeschaut
nee ich gucke gewöhnlich kein super rtl
also generell die diskussion startet ja
schon immer bei diesem kojoten der den
der diesen road runner oder frohe tom
und jerry vorher genau der held mit 10
10 die luft gesprengt wird und mit
hammer und amboss und so weiter in die
straße gebaut wird und so weiter und so
fort
gewalt ist immer da gewalt ist
unterhaltsam nicht umsonst gibt es
gewalt sportarten boxen ist zum beispiel
ein riesen ufc fan
das ist ultimate fight genommen was ist
sie klappert das ist eine super geile
frage weil es kommt also eigentlich aus
midway nix martial arts ja okay und bin
dann irgendwann ab ob chagaev sie
gelandet
ich finde es ist mittel zum zweck der
unterhaltung
es lässt sich schön aufwendig produziert
das lässt sich gut in szene setzen
gewalt ist immer eine sache mit der man
spielen kann weil viele leute
beispielsweise so ganz berühmte szenen
somit fingernagel rausziehen und so was
ganz ganz fieses wenn man zum beispiel
sich in den kinosessel kalt und denke
das sind halt sachen damit lässt sich
gut arbeiten
mal abgesehen davon muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen ich gut arbeiten im sinne
von emotionen werden aus ja ja das auf
jeden fall emotionen immer ob es jetzt
leute scheiße finden oder auf leute
total feiern emotionen sind ja sowieso
immer partner für die gerade wenn zum
youtube geben immer
von allen seiten du selbst als youtuber
deine zuschauer sowieso aber gewalt ist
halt so eine sache
ja wenn man so wirklich wie ich jetzt so
videospiel fan und so weiter und so fort
und macht es halt gerne also action
tatsächlich glaube so eine romanze zu
drehen wir jetzt nicht so für mich was
sagst du denn dann deinen jugendlichen
die vielleicht gewalt auch so anwenden
dass sie wirklich jemand verletzen wie
differenziert man da nicht drin er gut
differenzieren weil er halt oder die
fiktive welt wobei ich sagen muss wenn
man gewalt so drastisch darstellt wie
ich schlag niemanden die zähne aus oder
zumindest im seltensten fall dass man
irgendwie geschlagen wird nachdem also
wenn man das so drastisch darstellt ist
es glaube ganz gut zu differenzieren als
ein abstraktes mittel als tatsächlich
völlig überdrehte gewalt oder
gewaltexzess von mir aus auch und so
weiter und so fort wenn halt da jemand
erschossen wird bis zum gehtnichtmehr
worauf du ja sicherlich hinaus willst
dass man das als fiktive gewalt gut
differenzieren und abtun kann hoffe ich
auch aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
ich sehe diese kurzfilme auch nicht
unbedingt als bildungsauftrag okay das
ist jetzt nicht so dass ich sage und
liebe kinder daraus habt ihr gelernt
lehre munitions hülsen gehören in die
recycling tonne könnt ihr euch gleich
mal machen so genau
aber wie gesagt ich hoffe halt einfach
dass die leute da clever genug sind es
glaube ich von meiner community sogar zu
98 6 prozent dass sie wirklich smart
sind und wirklich smart genug sind und
jetzt nicht in die schule rennen leute
erschießen
gut so wie wir gamer dass er gerne tun
man wollte man mich dann nicht mehr
sagen weil es jetzt böse aber jetzt war
ja satire wir haben daher das ist ja
auch der punkt bisschen las war satire
das war wirklich alles so einfach zu
verstehen ja ja super geil supercool
schlicht zu wenig oder warum hast du so
dumm glauben ringe ja ich schlafe
unfassbar wenig echt ja zum beispiel
heute drei stunden
warum einmal 90 minuten zwei
schlafzimmern sind naja gestern batman
the dark knight rises im o-ton geguckt
okay da drüben schön auf englisch und so
den stürmer trotzdem scheiße
die müsste sie ja sogar in dem film
nochmal nach synchronisieren sich native
aufgeregt haben dass man sich versteht
richtig krass aber auf jeden fall super
geiler als die deutsche synchro
tatsächlich immer noch was meisterfeier
und wie gesagt war dann um 2 zu hause
und bin heute mit meiner freundin
zusammen auf 515 aufgestanden weil ich
gehofft habe noch ein video fertig
schneiden zu können wo ich kläglich
versagt was dadurch erst morgen schon
online ist wenn dieses video hier online
ist krass vierte wand durch brauchen
mehr zuschauer angucken aber es liegt
tatsächlich daran dass ich schlafen auch
nicht so mag ich find ja persönlich auch
das doch das ist richtig man braucht
halt ein minimum an schlafenden augen
gesehen hole ich mir ja auch es ist ja
nicht so dass ich ein wenig schlafe dass
ich irgendwo
psychosen kriege und tot umfalle aber es
gibt kein zustand der nähe am tod ist
als schlaf- und damit habe ich ein
problem löst ein problem ganz ganz ganz
ganz ganz ganz toll wenn ich auch ganz
empathie los kann mit dem thema
überhaupt nicht umgehen steht es sofort
von hier weg und deswegen glaube ich
dass spielt sogar da auch ein bisschen
mit rein wenn ich schlafe und ruhe dich
schlaf ich bin nur mit kopfhörern und so
weil ich das nicht ab kann wenn ich da
liege und anfangen gedanken zu machen
da kriege ich eine panne das ist
tatsächlich so ein ding da habe ich so
da habe ich meine kleine klatsche
wahrscheinlich vielleicht sogar eine
größere deswegen ist das schlafen echt
nicht so meins nicht schafft dann halt
auch wirklich wenn ich todmüde bin dann
so tag weg das geht gut okay ich nehme
jetzt mal eine grüne okay
wieso engagiert du dich so stark sozial
weil es wichtig ist weil es viele viele
viele viele elternhäuser gibt die gerade
probleme mit kindern haben und ich meine
jetzt nicht eltern mit
migrationshintergrund ich meine nicht
gewalttäter jugendliche gewalttäter die
irgendwen verprügeln und so weiter und
so fort was ja immer im fokus steht das
heißt ja immer oh nein sie bösen
ausländer verprügeln irgendwie schüler
auf dem schulhof an so was was schon mal
völlig schwachsinnig weil deutsche
grünen also und b überhaupt nicht so im
fokus stehen sollte weil das richtig
schwer ist sind eltern oder ist es was
richtig wichtig ist es eltern zu helfen
unter die arme zu greifen
die nichts offensichtlich falsch machen
die gutes elternhaus mit einer soliden
basis darstellen und die dann
beispielsweise ein kind was in 11
zwölften klasse in versuchten suizid auf
dem gymnasium begeht und so weiter zu
helfen was nie im fokus steht was nicht
in die medien kommt worauf keiner blickt
von auch pädagogen meist keinen blassen
schimmer haben lehrer jetzt speziell
meine ich wirklich da ist es wirklich
wichtig einzugreifen
das ist auch das was die leute vergessen
das ist diesen oberflächlich so
glamourösen tollen suzuki haiti tätig
familien unter der oberfläche richtig
richtig dreckig gehen kann und deswegen
gerade weil es die leute halt auch nicht
wissen sich selbst zu helfen es ist
irgendwann ist der punkt da können sie
sich nicht mehr sehr weit
und dann wird es wichtig dass man da auf
jeden fall rein grätscht und sagt jetzt
hier eine notbremse wir müssen auf jeden
fall uns mal unterhalten wenn auch
wirklich mit der ganzen familie zum
systemischen ansatz dass man mit den
leuten redet da gewisse strukturen
aufbricht und so weiter und so fort
und da guckt wirklich was da vergraben
ist und das entgeht den meisten und das
entgeht so vielen dass es immer wieder
menschen in dem alter gibt den
selbstmord begehen was ich unfassbar
traurig wenn nämlich verstehen kann wenn
man sich mit mit 13 14 jahren
beispielsweise mit putzmitteln ertränkt
unsere geschichten
das ist heftig und so was beispielsweise
haben kollegen bei mir in der
schulpsychologie erlebt solche
geschichten und das ist der erste hilfe
schreien übersehen wurde ist es dann
meistens wirklich zu spät
und deswegen ist es so wichtig sich
sozial zu engagieren gerade gerade auch
in den härtefällen mit denen sich sonst
keiner so wirklich auseinandersetzen
will oder die nicht die nicht publiziert
war genug sind wo man keine geile story
daraus machen können eben weil die
eltern das kind nicht grün und sonst was
das ist so dass mir da gibt auch eine
menge anderen frauen von gewalt letzte
rote die letzte rote dies bestimmt voll
ist heftig krass gemacht und wir gucken
mal du trägst brillengläser stets dorf
superhelden waffen nun zombies wann
willst du endlich erwachsen werden
nein auf keinen fall ist das coole ist
dass wir ganz viele erwachsen bin ich
von 6 bis 18 uhr außer wenn ich frei
habe okay und dann nicht mehr gut dann
bin ich der der einst also es klingt
immer so ein bisschen aufgesetzt aber es
ist bei mir eins zu eins wie aus den
videos wenn ich also mit meinem jungen
leute irgendwo unterwegs bin dann
tatsächlich so natürlich scheiße
krankenversicherung also was geht klar
irgendwann ist man im alter da muss man
sich kümmern und so weiter und so fort
aber das sind nur facetten von
erwachsensein und der rest erwachsen
sein kann mich mal auf jeden fall gut
soll ich noch eine grüne machen
er kommt zum abschluss gut nochmal so
honig ums maul schmieren
auf geht's frage das heißt drauf warum
bist du so bodenständig geblieben ist
liegt einerseits an meinen eltern
andererseits an meiner freundin und
andererseits an meinem ganzen
freundeskreis frei ich habe in meinem
richtig doll engen freundeskreis nicht
viele youtube das tendiert so zwischen 2
und 0 sage ich mal
es ist wieder schwierig wie wie eng man
den freundeskreis fast aller aller aller
aller engsten freundeskreis gibt es
niemand wissen mit youtube
auseinandergesetzt auseinandersetzt und
so in meinem weiteren richtig guten
freundeskreis sag ich jetzt mal mit dem
ich wirklich viel zu tun habe gibt es
auch nur verdammt wenig leute und wenn
man halt außer wenn man sich die zeit
für die tube nimmt nicht nur an youtube
hängt sondern etwas anderes hat was
glaube dafür wichtig ist für dieses
bodenständig bleiben oder sein wenn es
das eigentlich gar kein problem
hattest du mir im moment also so ein
pick-up bemerkt und ich komme mir aus
diesem aus dieser anonymität raus ich
werde bekannter wurde so nicht gab sie
sondern erlebt dass sie ganz normal aber
die straße ja wobei ich ja da zum
beispiel die anonymität in berlin sehr
schätze meine geliebte heimatstadt zum
beispiel war ja der totale kulturschock
für total setzt genau das war der totale
kulturschock für die beiden weil die
sich tierisch gewundert haben die
kommentare aus dem ort und die sind
total drauf ab gegangen dass ich ihn
jemand anspricht und deswegen liebe ich
berlin einfach weil die leute
respektieren dass auch einfach mal wenn
die sehne war was zieht der für eine
fresse sagt jetzt mal so bergler weil
ich ja eigentlich nicht oft böse gucken
aber es ist hier tatsächlich entspannter
es ist hier so entspannt dass ich halt
nicht ständig angesprochen werde ich war
ja von manchen youtuber die werden am
tag 15 mal angequatscht ich habe
überhaupt kein problem damit wenn mich
jemand anspricht wenn er freundlich ist
wer foto will muss freundlich sein okay
aber gar nicht ich mache gerne fotos mit
meinen leuten
nach gerne irgendwie keine ahnung
gestern zum beispiel eine schlange
gestanden und kurzes pläuschchen
gehalten und so absolut alles kein thema
aber es ist für mich jetzt nicht wichtig
ich halte mich daran nicht fest ich kann
mich daran nicht auch für mich
irgendjemand wenn mich irgendjemand an
quatscht lose gibt mir gar nichts also
auch krass was ich immer für die jetzt
zum beispiel aber ist es nicht ein teil
also es gibt mir auf jeden fall das ist
das super ich finde das positive
feedback ganz ganz toll ich ganz ganz
toll wenn sich leute trauen einen
anzusprechen
auf jeden fall aber es ist nicht
insofern gibt es mir nicht dass es dass
es für mich jetzt dass ich mich daran
irgendwie hoch ziehen muss und deswegen
also wenn mich einer erkennt können kann
fast sagen auf jeden fall aber hier in
berlin es ist nicht selten dass du ja
gerade selber abschluss ist air berlin
ist auffallend entspannt definitiv gut
dann bleibt weiter so entspannt war in
berlin gar kein problem der super und
noch mehr fragen lotto gibt es natürlich
auch klicks und zum beispiel im café di
gio rc der einzige kandidat der wirklich
mal ausgerastet ist aber sich dann auch
schnell wieder beruhigt hat und sehr
lustig natürlich auch das mit nora
tschirner die erklärt warum sie nicht
twittert ja und das könnt ihr in dem und
das andere in dem fragen lotto und
natürlich viel viel mehr sehen viel spaß
bis dann